welcome to CBS this morning Iran's
supreme leader says his country's
revenge against the u.s. is not over
after Iran's first military retaliation
to the killing of general Qasem
Soleimani but the country's foreign
minister says Iran does not seek
escalation Iranian TV says this video
shows ballistic missiles being fired at
us troop locations in Iraq last night
more than a dozen missiles were aimed at
the al-assad base in western Iraq and a
base in Erbil two of the sites where
American troops are located president
Trump tweeted last night all is well
after the attacks and boasted we have
the most powerful and well-equipped
military anywhere in the world by far
adding to the rising tension in the
region a ukrainian passenger jet crashed
outside iran's capitol overnight killing
all 176 passengers and crew there were
63 Canadians on board but no Americans
there are no indications right now this
crash is related to the missile attacks
we have a team of correspondents
covering the crisis in the Middle East
with the latest developments and we
begin with Holly Williams in Baghdad
Holly was anyone hurt in the Iranian
missile strikes good morning well it is
now day time here in Iraq time to assess
the damage done by this barrage of
Iranian missiles Iraq's military says
that it suffered no casualties
and remember they work very closely with
American troops here but so far there's
been no official word from the US side
the missile streaked across the night
sky shattering the peace at around 2
a.m. local time Iran making good on its
threat of revenge the main target
al-assad base covers an area of 25
square miles and it's home to around
1,500 US and coalition troops president
Trump visited the base in 2018 with this
message for Iran and to protect us
interests and also to always watch very
closely over any potential reformation
of Isis and also to watch over Iran
we'll be watching to the north Erbil air
base has been critically important in
the fight against Isis we visited
several times it's home to US personnel
and aircraft this is apparently one of
the missiles that Iran launched at Erbil
but it landed in a town 30 miles away
local reports say there were no
casualties the roughly 5,000 US troops
here in Iraq were already on high alert
they paused their operations against
Isis fearing retaliation after President
Trump ordered the assassination on a
Baghdad Street of Iranian general Qasem
Soleimani just hours before the mesial
attack we met with General Abdul Karim
hala military spokesman for iraq's prime
minister he told us he was fearful that
his country would become a battlefield
for Iran and the United States today
that frightening prospect looks one step
closer in a part of the world that is
already unstable and ravaged by Wars
that frightening prospect is terrifying
for many people in the region the key
question now is how the US will respond
indeed Holly Williams was in Baghdad
Holly thank you very much
you